Interviewer: As a message to viewers who are trying to get their lives together,
young people trying to find their way through this increasingly dangerous minefield of politics that divides us today.
How do they know which rules of thumb and signposts they can use to see if they are on the right track?
Is what I learn, or what attracts me politically, inspired by what is best for my community?
Peterson: That requires careful thought and prayer,
if you want to approach it in a traditional way, you have to orientate yourself and determine your direction.
That is a process of self-examination:
What is your direction, where do you want to go? And the answer can just be 'nowhere'.
That is why I created the 'Future Authoring Program'.
You have to choose a direction, otherwise you are directionless. You turn around in a circle,
and you suffer, and so do the people around you. It is not a good solution.
Choose your direction, choose your goal.
You have to find out what it is, what works for you.
What purpose justifies all the suffering that you do in your life?
Begin to answer that question.
You will get better and better, it is a personal process.
And you must use your education to provide you with information. You also need a personal point of view.
If you don't have it, it will be handed to you.
And that may make you a puppet, a slave to other people's goals.
So I would say: what are the processes?
What I recommend to people is: clean up your room.
That's a good start. Organize the landscape immediately around you.
Organize your time. Begin to control yourself.
See if you can stop saying things that you know are lies.
That is not the same as telling the truth. You are not that far in the beginning yet,
you're not good enough to even try it.
But anyone can stop saying things that they know are untruths.
You can define that yourself.
Interviewer: good, but in your definition of untruths this also means:
the higher level of moral inaccuracies.
Peterson: indeed, it is a wrong way of life.
Interviewer: you can say something that is literally true, but in your view it is a 'black' truth,
morally speaking. You want to achieve a negative social goal with it.
Peterson: I could also say: stop saying things that go against your conscience.
Instead of talking about untruths. Because what is true?
But what about this: stop saying and doing things that make you feel weak.
There how to just pay attention. Some things make you feel disintegrating, that is a physical sensation. Disintegrated and weak.
That is something Carl Rogers wrote about.
He saw it as a part of ...
... I have lost the word, it was something like integrity ...
but he did not use that word.
Some things increase your integrity and others disintegrate.
You often disintegrate the things you do to impress other people.
Or because you are taking the shortest route. You escape your moral duty.
Your moral duty flows naturally from your goals.
As soon as you have goals, you have moral obligations. They belong together.
Because the moral duty prescribes what you must do to achieve your goals.
And if you have no goal, you are aimless. So that is not a solution.
So with the goals comes the moral duty. And if you violate it, then you feel it.
Then you know: I shouldn't do that.
That could be, it's not necessary. This is not necessary.
But I would say you can start there. You start small.
Actually it is not small. Last night a girl came to me after my lecture, and that happens very often.
She said: I started tidying up my room last year, and that has completely changed my life.
She said: Your room is a reflection of your mind. And that is true.
That is absolutely true.
As you are in your room, so is your room YOU.
People don't think that way, but that doesn't matter. It doesn't matter if they think like that, it's like that.
So clean up what you can tidy up and stop saying things that make you feel weak.
And then you will know what to do.